in this video I want to talk about
enzymes and this first video about
enzymes is going to be a brief intro
okay and just kind of what they are why
we're they're important to biochemistry
and that sort of deal so enzymes you
might have heard them referred to as
biological catalysts biological
catalysts and if you've learned about
catalysts before in general chemistry
you know that catalysts increase the
rate of a reaction right so in
biochemistry a lot of the things we're
going to talk about our particular
biochemical reactions reactions that
happen by a lot in biological systems
and nearly all of them are our enzyme
catalyzed so it's important understand
enzymes and how they work so that we can
understand those reactions better so
enzymes are biological catalysts and
most of them most of them are proteins
most actually nearly all of them are
proteins and which is why we learned
about protein structure in the previous
videos because again if why not
understand enzymes and they are their
proteins and we need to understand
protein structure in order to understand
something a function we need to know
it's its structure and how that sort of
works the reason why I said most is
because some some RNAs catalyze their
own splicing not really terribly
important but at least not for this
video but that's why I wrote most but
pretty much all the ones that we'll be
talking about in future videos are
proteins so how is it that enzymes
increase the rate of video yet increase
the rate of a reaction what they do is
you probably ready know this they lower
the activation energy of a reaction they
lower the activation energy right and
specifically they do they lower the
activation energy without altering
without altering the thermodynamics of
the reaction
okay now what do I mean by that
activation energy that's that's an
ordeal or a thought or an idea that
deals with kinetics and and which is not
thermodynamics essentially what I want
to get out here is something a very very
important idea and that is that the
delta g of a reaction is not altered or
changed it's not altered or changed by
an enzyme okay so this essentially means
that if a reaction has a delta g that's
negative and it will stay negative right
or specifically if a the delta g of a
particular reaction is negative seven
kilocalories then that reaction will
always have a delta g of negative seven
kilocalories no matter what enzyme you
attach it just going to help the
reaction achieve that that you know
completion earlier or quicker okay so
so spend in addition how do they lower
the activation energy they're actually
before I get to that another thing they
do is they they increase rate constants
they increase rate constants and if you
if you kind of don't remember what what
the rate constant is let me just sort of
show you here briefly if you remember
rate laws used to be written in G chem
like this where this rate equals k times
the substrate contour should be the
reactant concentration raised to a
certain reaction order so these are the
reactants in a reaction and these are
their orders which sort of tell you how
to what extent changing the
concentration of the substrate or the
reactants increases the rate of the
reaction so if you increase the if you
want to increase the rate of the
reaction you either increase the
concentration of the reactants or you
can increase the rate constant so that's
sometimes some enzymes what they'll do
is they'll they'll increase rate
constants okay now another thing that
another idea that we need to talk about
when we talk about enzymes is
what enzymes really bind to and/or what
binds enzymes and the term that is used
for things that bind an enzyme is a
substrate and so substrates bind to
enzymes and specifically they bite at a
particular location they bind at what's
called the active site okay so what is
the active site the active site is just
an area that is part of the protein
where the substrate is supposed to bind
so kind of give you a little a little
idea of what that sort of looks like is
if you have a protein that's or a
specific enzyme it looks like this okay
it looks like this and there's like a
portion of it looks like a look like
that let's just call this the active
site that's where the substrate is
supposed to bind right and notice it's
kind of like a semicircle here okay
imagine that is the active site that
means that the substrate would probably
be something circular right so this
would be a substrate that would bind
here right so if once it's bound it
would look like this right something
like that okay and actually notice note
that this is here the enzyme II okay so
the active site is just an area that is
particular to where the substrate binds
and what I want to note here is that
it's very very specific enzymes are very
specific for what they bind so for
instance or one thing that we mentioned
I think before when we're talking about
cellulose versus starch for instance or
glycogen is that the alpha linkages
versus the beta linkages now that's
those are sort of stereoisomers
sometimes an enzyme will catalyze the
reaction for a particular stereoisomer
and not the other so although those are
you know it could be nearly identical in
structure the enzyme still might not
work okay so they're very very specific
sometimes even stereospecific
okay now exactly what do they do they do
this thing what they do is they what do
enzymes
the way they lower the activation energy
okay is they stabilize the transition
state I'm writing this in all caps
because I feel this is very important
stabilize the transition state what is
that this transition state before I go
on is sort of denoted by this little
cross with - or this little line with
two crosses okay so I'm going to draw
this diagrams free energy diagram for uh
what's it called oops
so you may have seen this before a free
energy diagram learn like this we're
talking about enzymes we think about
this diagram where on the y axis we have
free energy Gibbs free energy right
which is G of course right and the x
axis is reaction progress going to the
right so as the reaction progresses so
if we think about it we let's say we
have reactants at this particular energy
level right now I'll label this
interesting as the reaction progresses
we have to go up in energy reach a
certain point and then we come back in
the reaction goes to completion okay so
let me know some details about this so
initially here we have some reactants at
this particular energy level so we have
reactants that that's kind of small if
you can't read that that is reactants
over here at the end of the reaction
after reaction is come to completion we
have products okay now before we can
actually before we the reaction can
actually proceed towards products it has
to go up in energy before it comes down
energy and actually before I go on about
that I want to note here that this
particular reaction I have here has a
negative Delta G okay so Delta G is just
the the product the energy of the
products minus the energy of the
reactants so the
Delta G here is actually in this case
negative because the products energy is
lower than the reactants so the final
energy minus the initial energy will
give you a negative value so this is a
spontaneous reaction but we forward but
before we can actually have this
reaction occur spontaneously we need to
reach this particular energy level
before the reaction proceeds towards the
products now that energy as you may know
already is called the activation energy
okay so the energy between the reactants
here alright that difference in energy
from here to here is the EA or the
activation energy okay fret to note that
here EA okay now what an enzyme does is
it lowers the end D activation energy so
you might already know right that that
if you have so this white line sort of
that I've drawn here so far is the
uncatalyzed reaction right now if I
include a let's go to a violet line so
what happens is we we lower this
activation energy here we lower it right
it's not as high before the before the
reaction proceeds to the products in
that what we've done is we've made the
activation energy only this high right
so the activation energy for the
catalyzed reaction is lower
how does that actually happen well I
mentioned this whole idea of a
transition state and what the transition
state essentially is it's a high energy
intermediate between between the
reactants and the products right if you
recall back from like from organic
chemistry the idea of an sn2 reaction
there was the pentavalent intermediate
where carbon sort of has five things
bound to it even though it really
doesn't that high-end that's a high
energy intermediate that's sort of the
same idea here there's a transition
state at this point here right the
transition state exists here that's that
high energy that high energy is due to
this transition state obviously the
transition state is going to be
different for you know for different
reactions but the whole idea is that
that the transition state
is a high-energy intermediate so what we
do is we stabilize it now stable means
low energy right so if stable means low
energy and we stabilize the transition
state we lower the energy of the
transition state and that is actually
how we lower the activation energy so
that allows that what that allows for is
it's more likely that reactants will
reach that activation energy they'll
reach that that uh that that activation
energy and begin to proceed to products
more easily okay which and essentially
that just means the reach products
faster so that is particularly how how
enzymes work and I hope that was that's
pretty helpful I'll see you in the next
video when they talk about Michaelis
Menten the michaelis-menten model and
things involving that